the iPhone has transformed the fate of
mankind not only is iPhone a mini
computer that fits in the palm of your
hand
but it is the culmination of decades of
technology and innovation bundled into
one small device today after over 10
generations of evolution the iPhone has
become so prominent that there is about
a 20% chance that you're watching this
video right now with an iPhone Alfa has
come to dominate the smartphone market
glaring so much control they're
basically able to set the prices for the
whole market they were able to connect
mankind at a level never before seen and
have revolutionize how people interact
politically economically geographically
and socially the iPhone and Apple can be
tied back to one man's vision for the
world the one and only Steve Jobs but
what if Steve Jobs is never born
what if Apple was never created what if
their most successful product the iPhone
never materialized how would all of that
transform our lives today many people
assume that Apple invented the
smartphone but this is actually not true
and a smartphone dates back way before
the iPhone was even conceptualized the
first true smartphone actually managed
debut in 1992 it was a Simon Personal
Communicator created by IBM if you
thought that the iPhone was expensive
IBM Simon actually ran nearly $900 in
1992 equating to over 1400 dollars in
today's money
the Simon was far ahead of its time
though he had a monochrome LCD
touchscreen measuring 4.5 inches by 1.4
inches for a size reference it's a
little bit shorter in height and about
half the width of an iPhone Plus device
aside from calling you could use
assignment ascend to receive emails take
a look at the calendar write notes
scroll through the world time and even
schedule appointments and download
third-party apps while the Simon would
not receive widespread acclaim like the
iPhone or Android phones IBM did manage
to sell about 50,000 units so clearly
the concept of a smart device I could
handle all of her daily needs had
already not only been pondered about but
even put the practice before the iPhone
but this idea hadn't really caught on
and it wasn't very practical and used
for Simon you had to use established and
navigate through the phone
imagine having a text with the stylus
seeing that three typing bubbles flashy
four
seconds just to see the text okay would
be the norm
clearly this simply wasn't going to work
and that's why smartphones really
weren't very popular during the late
1990s and early 2000s instead during
this time there was a different mark
leader blackberry they had a stronghold
on a foreign market even a couple years
after the launch of the iPhone
Blackberry phones were as capable as
iPhones they had everything from
calendars to music to internet access
they even had a physical keyboard and
trackpad which were much prefer over
typing on glass one letter at a time but
what about the smartphone lineup well
around the same time Apple is developing
the iPhone Android OS hard at work with
their own operating system that could be
widely used among smartphones that's
right
Google wasn't working on Android Android
was working on Android as an arrow was
action an independent company
established in 1998 and Google actually
wouldn't buy Android Co 2005 for 50
million dollars so Android 2 would have
come out despite the iPhone not being
released in the first ever Android phone
t-mobile g1 will come out in October of
2008 so if everything up until now would
have unfolded the same way
what role did Apple play in a smartphone
market well Apple was always a premium
brand name from their mac books or
washes to their smartphones Apple had
the high quality premium devices and
this really drove a lot of attention to
smartphone market and really made
smartphones much more desirable without
Apple the smartphone market wouldn't
have gone as fast as smartphones
wouldn't have been as appealing
innovation would have also stalled while
Apple's newer devices don't offer many
new features their original devices were
brimming with innovation from Siri to
touch ID to eye message the smartphone
market as a whole would have moved
forward at a much slower rate long for a
vast range of different possibilities
first of all people were not flocked
away from the BlackBerry nearly as
quickly in fact they may have never left
blackberry at all if we were assuming
the Android space develops in the same
manner but slower the conversion rate
Android would be much slower it wasn't
actually till the iPhone 6 that Apple
really penetrated the market and made
the iPhone a casual device across
Western countries until then
blackberry was the clear choice as it
was much cheaper
fighter pretty much all the same
functions an iphone offers without the
iphone this breakthrough point for
smartphones but I've come much later as
in several years later and Blackberry
would have kept their lead in the phone
market but eventually this change would
still occur so at this point who to play
Apple's role as a premium device with
the rivalry operating system
what about Samsung and LG who controlled
the largest portion of the smartphone
market after Apple today these companies
really didn't start offering premium
devices until a couple of years ago the
first really premium Samsung device was
the Samsung Galaxy s6 until then the
Galaxy series that plastic backs and
Samsung wasn't competing with Apple
head-on they were trying to attract the
utilitarian demographic who would buy
the Samsung phones for the advantages
that are provided like expandable
storage and highly customizable Android
operating system it wasn't till as
Samsung Galaxy s6 the Samsung really
started to compete in the smartphone
market using brand and revised image as
opposed to the purpose they fulfilled so
if Apple wasn't there here's the first
theory on how things could have turned
out first of all if the iPhone hadn't
been released
Goom may have never started licensing
Android for other smartphone companies
to use and kept Android to themselves we
may have seen the rise of Google phones
as the super customizable phone that
everyone wanted their hands on and all
the competitors would be on their own to
develop their own operating system to go
along with their own phones but I don't
think that this is a very likely outcome
as Google cares more about getting their
name out with their products like
Android Gmail and Google Drive and
actually driving profit through these
streams as well their main business
models built off of driving more traffic
to google.com considering this guru
would rather license out Android
offering it for a really cheap price to
companies in order to really get their
Android out there they weren't profit
much if any from the licensing of
Android but they would drive hundreds of
millions and more people on to remain
service google.com from all the people
who bought Android phones so Google
probably would have not not licensed out
Android so moving on to a second
possibility another tech giant may have
branched out from Android and launcher
own operating system this could be
anyone from smartphone Giants like
Samsung LG Motorola and HTC
but as I discussed before considering
that this company started with Android
there'd be a lot of backlash if they
suddenly switched to their own operating
system I think that such a phone would
actually come from a company that
doesn't have much of a presence in the
smartphone market today but does have
vast resources to make such a product a
reality like Sony Microsoft or Dell a
startup company really wouldn't be able
to do this as it would be very difficult
to create an operating system that a
significant amount of people would
prefer over Android from Google Plus
such a feat will require much more
capital than any venture capital firm
would be willing to provide to the
chance of a start-up like banana or
something taking over is quite slim but
there is a pretty good chance that one
of the other technology giants would
have done this and that brings me into
third theory what about the market
leader at the time blackberry they had
the resources and the audience to make
such a transition into smartphone market
plus considering that the smartphone
market would be evolving at a much
slower pace this would give a blackberry
a lot more time to recognize this trend
toward smartphones and it would be much
less likely they're just left and dust
like they are in our present timeline
also even to this day blackberry uses
their own operating system so in this
alternate timeline blackberry would be
in the perfect position to take off his
smart phone market and launch a
revolutionary device now if they
actually go through what this is a
completely different argument but they
definitely would have the best chance of
playing the role of Apple assuming that
blackberry seizes this moment and builds
a smartphone Empire what else could
change well if we take a look the iPhone
and the rise of the smartphone industry
as a whole has also heavily impacted
carriers if you take a look at t-mobile
stock prices you can see a sharp decline
after his launch of the iPhone and rise
of smartphones this was because iPhone
launched exclusively with AT&T and the
issue was that even after t-mobile was
supported at large by the smartphone
market t-mobile just couldn't keep up
with the constantly updating standards
from 2g all the way to 4G LTE they
simply didn't have their resources or in
this case the towers to support all of
this growth and they too would be left
in a dust just like blackberry yes today
however after the appointment of a new
CEO John Leger they would stage an epic
back but with us such a fast-paced
progression of smartphones in our
alternate timeline t-mobile may have
never lacked behind maybe they wouldn't
be forced offered dubiously cheaper form
plans and phone plan prices wouldn't be
dragged down nearly as quickly as they
have today in our alternate timeline
smartphones as a whole would not be as
common as they are among teens and
middle school and high school as they
are today so what would happen to a lot
of apps on the App Store surely
revolutionary mobile games were no
longer be revolutionary games like clash
of clans in clash Royale would not have
nearly as big of a target audience when
mobile games have even risen to become
eSport titles and what about social
media apps that kids nowadays are
addicted to like Instagram and snapchat
would they even exist today 90% of
snapchat users are from the age 13 to 24
so if smartphones had really spread
among kids would apps like snapchat vine
and tic toc even be created this would
have given social media giants so much
more time to launch their own services
maybe instead of Facebook having to buy
instrument whatsapp it would have
created the services on their own maybe
putter would have launched a vine
instead of having to buy them and that's
all just touching the surface of what
could have happened with doct
I phone what about Amazon uber and all
the other smartphone apps that we
haven't grown accustomed to and all the
services that people use on a daily
basis like Apple pay what about the
jailbreaking community there's no reason
to jailbreak Android so unless whoever
comes to dominate the smartphone market
doesn't allow for much customization
this community would never exist maybe
people would be proud to jailbreak their
BlackBerry's instead clearly a world
without the iPhone is almost like an
alien civilization no just kidding but
there are so many distinct day-to-day
differences that would arise from such a
reality and hey there may be a lot of
good things that arise from such a
reality as well maybe in 2019 people
wouldn't be as addicted to their
smartphones
maybe kids would engage in much more
social activities maybe we'd all have
more money if we weren't constantly
buying your iPhone for crazy high prices
and maybe we'd all be healthier but
those are all just possible outcomes the
iPhone was never invented what about
MacBooks
Apple watches and of course what would
we ever do without a one
Apple modernist and make sure to drop a
like you've related to CBS on those as
well but I think we would all agree that
the iPhone has touched all of our lives
in one way or another and I think that
we'd all agree to the iPhone is one of
the most revolutionary products of our
generation but that's not half of you
guys on the eye toward major comment
down below what you would like me to
cover next also if you guys like this
video make sure drop a like and consider
subscribing if I see more videos just
like this one but until then I'm worried
I'll see you guys all next week
[Music]